bom vocês podem perceber que eu acho que
é a coisa mais interessante que existe
hoje está vivendo
vocês devem ter sim
no seu dia a dia a quantidade de
informações que vocês têm um curto
espaço de tempo
sabe de uma coisa ser humano dizem os
especialistas eu não sou da área serão
mantém aproximadamente 60 mil anos de
história
aproximadamente 25 mil anos a gente
errou em everton da face da terra mais
11 mil anos atrás 20 tirou o começo do
mês de cágado o cachorro e assim vai a
só sete mil anos a gente desenvolveu uma
chamada escrita a partir desse momento a
gente começou a se desenvolver um pouco
mais na nossa parte filosófica
só que somente dois mil e setecentos e
cinquenta anos atrás é que a gente teve
algumas pessoas que foram fortes na
nossa sociedade muda confúcio e sócrates
a partir disso a gente teve uma grande
loucura na nossa sociedade acontecendo
só que é mais interessante várias
sociedades ocorreram mas pensa uma coisa
somente há 200 anos atrás é que a gente
teve uma real modificação só porque sim
pode falar de toda a filosofia van que a
gente pode imaginar mas somente 200 anos
atrás já que a gente teve uma grande um
grande fato há 200 anos atrás de 800
milhões de habitantes a 2.750 anos atrás
de 600 milhões de habitantes de repente
em 200 anos a gente pula para 7 bilhões
e especialistas dizem 200 300 400
milhões o que significa isso
num curto espaço de tempo de 200 anos a
gente entrou com uma coisa chamada
mecânica
depois entrou com uma coisa chamada
elétrica depois com uma coisa chamada
eletrônica com tecnologia da informação
e agora durante a minha apresentação
muito de vocês estavam conectando com
algumas pessoas
aliás já está conectado agora neste
exato instante percebi que esse fato da
conexão e esse fato da data da coisa do
ser humano tentar se sobrepor é uma
coisa fundamental a gente vê várias
coisas acontecendo mas fundamentalmente
a maior conseqüência foi que nós mudamos
os nossos hábitos e esses hábitos é que
nos fazem sentir um pouco diferentes por
exemplo a gente comemorou há pouco tempo
atrás um dia fatídico para as mulheres
que basicamente em 1857
algumas mulheres que trabalhavam 16
horas por semana e resolveu reclamar
nesse processo de reclamação bingo foram
colocadas dentro de uma cela e queimadas
a isso se dê o dia das mulheres uma
lembrança isso a gente melhorou como a
sociedade perceba
então dentro dessa contextualização eu
quero botar que a gente no mundo de
muitas mudanças nesse mundo é muito
bacana gente muito bacana gente está
vivendo é uma honra está vivendo agora
sobre mim
só tem um detalhe a gente sempre olha
para as grandes realizações e percebe
grandes pessoas
eu sempre fui um aluno mediano super
mediano
aliás diga se passagem eu lutava com a
média não era um grande aluno e só
porque eu era contra essa média
basicamente eu gostava de fazer algumas
coisas 34 coisas mas na nossa sociedade
temos que ser da média em média que nem
campeonato brasileiro de futebol o
futebol por si só se faz três pontos se
ganha uma partida e se empata 3 e faz a
mesma coisa ganhar um perdedor se você
coloca todo mundo numa média e porque
pela própria característica do trabalho
que nós desenvolvemos basicamente se
você olha essa figura essa figura
fantástica parece uma sala de aula mas
não é é uma fábrica
nós somos ensinados a ser assim fomos
formados nesse contexto e se você
perceber a primeira coisa que você vai
olhar é que todas as pessoas são
praticamente iguais e nessa época que eu
estudava tinha uma banda chamada pink
floyd
ela tinha uma música que colocava todo
mundo como um tijolinho na parede e eu
ficava revoltado
dentro dessa lógica bom o tempo passou
as fábricas não mudaram muito
continua mais ou menos a mesma lógica só
que tem um detalhe a gente chega nesse
exato momento da nossa história em que a
gente consegue ser humano desenvolver a
tecnologia de uma tal maneira que as
máquinas começam a conversar conosco
antigamente chamado a dizer face um
homem máquina agora a gente fala
interface máquina e aí como é que você
se comporta uma sociedade inteligência
artificial extremamente ampla
bom isso é uma outra lógica mas eu sei
que continua sendo gelado na hora que
você vê uma foto como essa continua com
a respiração de uma pessoa estudar eu
particularmente gostava mais do recreio
no recreio aprende todas as minhas
lógicas de sociedade e habilidades
cognitivas habilidades sociais e isso é
importante para mim
basicamente isso é tão importante que eu
não conseguia ser um excelente aluno
meu colégio resultado prático quando foi
informando aconteceu o inevitável não
sabia o que ia fazer porque a minha
sociedade minha escola não informa para
fazer alguma coisa a mim forma informa
não é então dentro de si dessa lógica eu
tive o apoio do meu pai meu pai
fantástico
meu pai me deu dois cursos específicos
de testes vocacionais e falei 'pai
beleza obrigado a fazer um teste
vocacional fiz um primeiro teste
jornalismo
o segundo teste de jornalismo meu pai
chegou a falar a senhora bicho fazer um
teste vocacional vou te levar para
conhecer o engenheiro
vamos conhecer o engenheiro foi lá me
conheceu o engenheiro engenheiro chegou
lá na fábrica em que trabalhava nem
falou o seguinte carlos e engenheiro é
uma coisa fantástica o engenheiro pode
projetar um monte de coisa
ele pode e assim me projetar um monte de
coisa você pode projetar uma enceradeira
fiquei enceradeiras que olhando pra ele
assim pais será de rapaz não tenho
sentido isso lógico enceradeira cara que
eu lembro de enceradeira minha época de
criança com a minha mãe porque se vocês
lembram se alguém lembra desse tipo de
enceradeira que tem em cima
basicamente uma enceradeira bacana
quando se levantava o cabo ele fazia um
barulho grande porque aumentava a
votação e você subir até ficar querendo
brincar com a mão em cima da cevadeira
então é fazer um movimento ele falou o
seguinte olha máquina como essa como é
danada de fabricação
você tem que projetar e fez movimentos
têm movimento fazer um movimento para
que ele faça translação e ainda tem que
cuidar na rotação e eu não esqueço esse
movimento dele com uma enceradeira em
dentro dessa contextualização foi assim
que eu decidir por vocação ser
engenheiro
eu fui fazer engenharia durante todo o
meu tempo engenharia o que aconteceu foi
uma coisa bem óbvia eu aprendi padrões
aprende modelos
aprendi sistemas não aprende nada de
criativo de criatividade e aprendi uma
coisa muito interessante o que eu não
gosto
aprendi a passar matérias e aprendi a
não gostar de coisas e ponto isso pra
mim era uma grande formação porque o que
eu não gosto eu já sei o que eu quero
para minha vida o que eu não gosto eu já
sei que não quero
agora o que eu gostava não tinha idéia
terminei a faculdade o tempo foi
passando obviamente tempo foi passando e
você vai tentando se encontrar e estudar
pra cá estudar para lá um belo que eu
conseguir
é um processo e entrei e virei professor
do instituto tecnológico de aeronáutica
ita em são josé dos campos em são paulo
aí eu aprendi duas coisas interessantes
coisas bacanas basicamente a primeira
coisa lá entrava os alunos que eram os
pops e entram ainda bons alunos
fantásticos passa uma seleção dá nada
se todo mundo é bom aluno porque que
você não vai ter uma coisa de confiança
com ele lá tem uma coisa chamada
disciplina consciente até prova em
contrário toda pessoa está na sua frente
é uma excelente pessoa e a melhor pessoa
que está na sua frente
o resultado prático nenhum professor
fica na sala de aula numa prova
não tem sentido todo mundo é boa pessoa
aliás faça a prova em casa porque você
tem que fazer a prova uma sala de aula
parado
isso me deu uma característica muito
interessante relacionamentos que não
tinha dificuldade com essa questão
uma outra coisa importante é o complexo
de vira-lata esses caras que montaram
essa substituição começará a montar 1950
o brasil não tinha estrada nancy 54
estava pensando em montar uma fábrica de
aviões
imagina que tupiniquim é esse o que é
interessante nessa mesma aula é essa
mesma época mais ou menos surgiram os
caras tribo embrapa petrobras e puxei
consumo conseguir construir grandes
corporações que são fantásticas
aí no item consegui tirar o meu complexo
de vira-lata que tudo é possível deste
sequeira estude bastante e aí comecei a
estudar e curiosamente dentro desse
processo todo virei projetista de
máquinas in enceradeira aproveitar
porque é uma máquina será derrubar o
tipo de máquina qualquer tem rotação e
translação sempre
então dentro dessa cultura robótica tudo
que você pode imaginar então dentro
dessa lógica foi muito bacana porque a
gente desenvolveu vários projetos
industriais e chegou um determinado
momento vários projetos que a coisa
começou a ficar volumosa foram milhares
de pessoas que passaram por lá
aprendendo e centenas de projetos
industriais até que um belo dia o senai
me convidou para fazer uma coisa
diferente
olha agora vamos construir atmosferas
vamos trabalhar na construção de
atmosferas e atmosfera é muito diferente
de lugar
se coloco um prédio bota uma máquina
conversa com gente bota um cara aqui um
carro lá e pronto
agora a atmosfera não há atmosfera é
complexa porque tem várias coisas que
não dependem dela e deixa que começou a
perceber que o trabalho legal não seria
simplesmente desenvolver pedigree de
gente estudiosos a fantástica mas você
tem uma alta capacidade de associação
depois montar redes e daí sim com esse
bafafá todo experimentar e aí começa a
coisa que danado é observar observar
basicamente é você poder é entender e
questionar muito mais do que ter
respostas eu não tô nem aí para as
respostas que as respostas são várias
estou muito mais interessado em
perguntar só sabe quem pergunta mais
criança criança que pergunta a tudo
responde é terrível ver criança falando
com adulto é aquela coisa toda criança
de dois anos 12 anos andando na rua e
você cercando a criança para que ela não
caia
o que a gente mais tenta neste processo
é encontrar os caras que são a dos
famosos todos esses caras que falar aqui
na frente vocês olharem o olho dessas
pessoas tenham de criança
todos os olhos de criança e isso é
fundamental você dá liberdade para
pessoas e criança na observação
o segundo ponto é você criar uma
atmosfera de associação
essa atmosfera de associação ela foi
fundamentalmente de baixo para cima não
é de baixo de cima para baixo não de
baixo para cima como todo mundo pensa
'se você no sistema não dá condições
para isso as pessoas não vão saber
porquê porque as pessoas latinas são
tradicionalmente protagonistas
todo mundo quer ser o dono do jogo você
tem que criar a estrutura para que essas
pessoas trabalhem como você faz isso
associando conectando e desenvolvendo
intuição desenvolvendo a caso a caso é
fundamental
deixe um médico junto com um cara da
área de humanas junto com o cara da
engenharia e ver o que vai acontecer se
não tem a minha ideia coloque vários
alunos e vários tamanho da distinção
trabalhamos você vai ver o que vai
acontecer
formar redes formar redes é uma coisa
fantástica porque dentro dessa
contextualização
a pior coisa que a gente entende de
formação de redes junto a um bando de
gente igual
o bando do time igual sendo que tinham
forma assim tem um extrovertido e
introvertido formar a rede não é botar
grupinho que pensa do mesmo jeito para
desenvolver uma determinada coisa é
fazer e respeitar esses preço esses
pressupostos esses requisitos que as
pessoas têm fundamentalmente com você
tem todas as estruturas e pode
experimentar e sobre essa experimentação
quando a gente começa a trabalhar a
gente percebe que as coisas começam a
sair eu vou falar um pouquinho sobre
isso aí a cnud nosso local
o problema é que você deve perceber ter
percebido que para fazer todas essas
coisas que eu falei para vocês
fundamentalmente o que a gente precisa
de gente e aí eu digo com muita
tranquilidade hoje depois de muito mais
de 40 anos de idade 47 ser mais exato
parece que não existe um mínimo disse a
mínima chance de ter a pessoa
inteligente só de um tipo
são vários tipos distintos são vários
concelhos e sinto que a gente precisa
desenvolver a inteligência é aquela
pessoa que está na média
qual é o ponto forte daquela pessoa na
média
basicamente essa revolução tem
acontecido no mundo todo hoje a gente já
tem três milhões e meio de pessoas no
planeta com algum tipo de carteira
assinada algum tipo de contrato de
trabalho e sabem disso de 7 bilhões um
pouco o que é mais drástico nessa
história mais interessante nessa
história é que das três milhões e meio
de pessoas que trabalham hoje um bilhão
de pessoas essas pessoas um bilhão de
pessoas estão profissões que não
existiam antes 2011 recebendo uma
revolução bizarra agora especialistas
são muito claros em dizer o seguinte
daqui a seis anos 65% das profissões que
vão existir ainda não existem que serão
ofertadas não existem ou seja olha que
mundo que a gente está e como é que a
gente consegue vão ensinar a mesma coisa
pra esse povo
a gente percebe que é o processo é um
pouco diferente a gente não pode colocar
dentro de uma média
o jovem por característica a gente tem
que parar de acreditar que o jovem não
toma decisão que o jovem não tem gosto a
gente experimenta aqui dentro
em vários habitats de educação
quando a gente coloca o jovem para ter
um poder de decisão as coisas acontecem
caso prático essa figura vários vários
jovens desenvolvendo uma vez só recebe
um motor elétrico recebem uma uma
bateria e saem fazendo o carro eles
fizeram eles desenvolveram o que é
interessante que a gente tem a mesma
possibilidade de desenvolver os
professores nem sabe tata que os
professores ficam com medo porque afinal
de contas se o jovem toma conta qual o
papel desse professor dentro de si
habitado
só que existe uma coisa
interessantíssima na nossa sociedade que
foi criada a gente tem aproximadamente
para daqui a quatro anos aproximadamente
metade da população que trabalha
indústria com mais de 45 anos de idade
essas pessoas não estão conectadas ea
coisa terrível ea gente precisa
desenvolver esse processo de conexão
nessas pessoas e horário que uma pessoa
mais velha tem em relação a pessoa mais
jovem completamente extinto ea gente faz
o mesmo jeito e as mulheres essa mulher
basicamente que a grande rota ela foi
que desenvolveu a liga com a lógica da
copacol uma linguagem de programação
fantástica e o que aconteceu na prática
ela morreu com 90 e poucos anos 90 e
poucos anos mas ela não conseguiu
arrastar um monte de mulheres para a
área de computação mundo hoje que você
não compra mais um smartphone você não
compra mais um computador você compra
uma conexão alguma coisa um significado
para alguma coisa é fundamental o
desenvolvimento de produtos sejam feitos
com as mulheres
isso parece uma nova lógica é esquisito
né mas não tem nem 15 por cento de
mulheres trabalhando no mundo do
trabalho ligado ao desenvolvimento de
produtos
bom estou querendo dizer pra vocês não
têm resposta não tem a gente vai estar
sempre em fase beta permanente e esse
nosso processo de construção da nossa
sociedade ele assim volátil mesmo não
não existe fórmula mágica para a gente
começar a pensar numa resolução positiva
ruim
a única coisa que eu sei que a gente
percebe é que existe hoje não existe
amanhã existe hoje e hoje é o processo
que a gente está desenvolvendo finaliza
e é essa essa apresentação é uma vez eu
conheci um cidadão que ele era
presidente da de uma grande corporação
automotivo e ele estava se aposentando
eu falei assim o luís se você quer mesmo
se aposentar você é um cara tão viver
não vou me aposentar porque tem um monte
de coisa bacana para ser feito
estava com 70 anos de idade ele tem os
75 anos de idade está terminando o
doutorado dele lá no ita com 70 anos de
idade começou doutorado e terminando com
maestria então hoje particularmente é o
mais importante ele fala sempre isso
seja confirmado pois inconformismo é
viver uma distância saudável dá para noé
obrigado gente pelo tempo você está
[Aplausos]
[Música]